one of the things that I always like
saying is sometimes that your best
ability is your availability we all know
how you have those type of people in
your life they're like they might not be
the most talented you ever see the uh
the Simon sinek uh who you trust versus
skill uh Matrix you ever seen that where
they interviewed what Navy Seals yeah of
what type of people you want to roll
with the people with the most skill or
who you trust the most right and it
wasn't even a question they would take
trust over skill any day of the week
because you can't buy trust loyalty
availability so there's you know back to
the men out here it's like you might not
be the best at what you do but if you
keep showing up day in and day out
that's loyalty right there that's just
that's a sort of a derivative of loyalty